♪.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP FAILING TO
FILL THE ARENA AFTER BRAGGING
THAT A MILLION PEOPLE WERE
TRYING TO ATTEND HIS RALLY.
>> HE PUSHED HIS STAFF TO HOLD
IT DESPITE CONCERNS AMONG SOME
OF THE TOP ADVISORS THAT IT WAS
TOO SOON TO BE BACK IN A RALLY
SETTING LIKE THIS.
AND WHAT IS LEFT HERE, SORT OF
AN EMBARRASSING SPECTACLE.
>> FAR LOWER THAN THE
EXPECTATIONS THAT THE
WHITE HOUSE AND THE PRESIDENT
HIMSELF PUT OUT.
THEY EXPECTED THIS ARENA TO BE
FULL.
YOU CAN SEE BEHIND ME THERE ARE
SEATS THAT ARE NOT FILLED.
>> FOR HIM, ALL HE CARES ABOUT
IS HOW IT LOOKS AND BOY, OH,
BOY, IT LOOKED EMBARRASSING FOR
HIM TONIGHT.
JEDEDIAH: OKAY.
SO YOU OBVIOUSLY SEE THAT MEDIA
MONTAGE CRITICIZING NUMBER OF
ATTENDEES AT THE TRUMP RALLY
LAST NIGHT.
WE HAVE SOMEONE WHO WAS THERE.
NEW YORK CONGRESSMAN LEE ZELDIN
JOINS THE SHOW NOW TO GIVE US A
LITTLE INSIGHT WHAT THE MOOD WAS
ACTUALLY LIKE.
SO CONGRESSMAN, IS THAT
CRITICISM BY MEDIA VALID OR, WAS
THERE A LOT OF ENERGY ON THE
GROUND AND ARE THEY WRONG?
>> OH, THE ENERGY WAS
OUTSTANDING.
EVERYBODY WHO WAS THERE, THEY
WERE EXCITED TO BE THERE.
THERE WERE PEOPLE WHO WERE
CAMPED OUT FOR DAYS WAITING FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET INTO THE
VENUE.
NOW AS FAR AS THE MEMBERS OF THE
MEDIA WHO WERE JUST COMMENTING
IF THERE WERE MORE PEOPLE THERE,
THEY WOULD BE COMPLAINING THAT
THERE ARE TOO MANY.
THEY WERE GOING TO, THEY SHOWED
THIS DAYS IN ADVANCE THEY WERE
GOING TO BE COMPLAINING ABOUT
THE AMOUNT OF PEOPLE WHO WERE
THERE REGARDLESS.
SO THERE IS THAT DYNAMIC.
OKLAHOMA IS DEEP INTO A
REOPENING.
JOE BIDEN IS CAMPAIGNING OUT OF
HIS BASEMENT.
THEY REALLY DON’T WANT PRESIDENT
TRUMP TO GET BACK ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL AND PRESIDENT
TRUMP IS THE TYPE OF PERSON WHO
WANTS TO GET AROUND AMERICA AND
BE ABLE TO DO THESE RALLIES AND
UNDERSTAND THERE IS A HUGE
STAKES ELECTION COMING UP IN
NOVEMBER AND PRESIDENT WANTS TO
BE OUT WITH THE PEOPLE BUT THE
ENERGY INSIDE OF THAT ARENA WAS
ABSOLUTELY FANTASTIC OF PEOPLE,
BLEEDING RED, WHYTE AND BLUE,
LOVING OUR COUNTRY, PRINCIPLED
PASSIONATE, THEY LOVE THEIR
PRESIDENT NOT JUST ENOUGH TO BE
SHOWING UP THERE BUT CAMPAIGNING
HARD TO GIVE HIM FOUR MORE YEARS
IN CONGRESS.
GRIFF: AOC MAKING BOLD CLAIMS.
TRUMP CAMPAIGN MANAGER BRAD
PARSCALE, SAYING THAT RADICAL
PROTESTERS FUELED BY A MEDIA
COVERAGE, INTERFERED WITH TRUMP
SUPPORTERS AT RALLY.
THEY EVEN BLACKED ACCESS TO THE
METAL DETECTORS PREVENTING
PEOPLE FROM ENTERING.
THANKS TO THE THOUSANDS THAT
MADE IT ANYWAY.
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ
GLOATING THIS, ACTUALLY YOU JUST
GOT ROCKED BY TEENS TICKTOK WHO
FLOODED TRUMP CAMPAIGN WITH
MILLION PEOPLE DURING COVID.
SHOUTOUT TO ZOOMERS.
Y’ALL MAKE ME SO PROUD.
CONGRESSMAN, YOUR REACTION.
>> WELL I THINK AOC SAID THE
QUIET PART OUT LOUD.
THE FACT THAT THEY, MEDDLE LIKE
THIS, THEY DON’T HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REGISTER FOR A
RALLY FOR JOE BIDEN BECAUSE, YOU
KNOW, JOE BIDEN IS HAPPENING OUT
IN HIS BASEMENT.
BY THE WAY IF JOE BIDEN WAS
HAVING A RALLY YESTERDAY, IN
TULSA, OKLAHOMA, FOR EXAMPLE,
THERE WOULD BE BARELY ANYBODY
THERE AT ALL.
WE SAW A LOT OF THE
BLACK LIVES MATTER PROTESTERS
AND THEIR ACTIVITIES TO PREVENT
INDIVIDUALS FROM BEING ABLE TO
GET INTO THE VENUE.
AND AGAIN, YOU HAD PEOPLE
CAMPING OUT THERE SINCE
WEDNESDAY.
THERE WERE A FEW DYNAMIC AT
PLAY.
I WAS SITTING NEXT TO ONE MEMBER
OF CONGRESS HAVING CONSTITUENTS
CONTACTING HIM, THEY HAD
REGISTERED TO COME BUT THEY
DIDN’T THINK THEY WOULD BE ABLE
TO GET IN IF THEY CAME DOWN.
REGARDLESS OF THAT, AMAZING,
ENERGY INSIDE OF THAT ROOM, THE
FOLKS WHO WERE THERE.
BUT AOCING BRAGGING ABOUT THEM
MEDDLE LINK LIKE THAT BECAUSE
THEY DON’T HAVE BETTER THINGS TO
DO?
ANOTHER SAD DYNAMIC AS I’M
COMING HERE TO THE STUDIO, GOT
INTO D.C. A FEW HOURS AGO, I’M
SEEING ALL THESE DIFFERENT
BUSINESSES BOARDED UP.
AS SUBSTANCE OF WHAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP IS TALKING ABOUT, AS YOU
LOOK AT SEATTLE AND EFFORT TO
DEFUND THE POLICE AND REALITY IF
YOU CALL 911 THERE IS INTRUDER
IN YOUR HOUSE, YOU DON’T WANT
THEM TO SEND A SOCIAL WORKER
THEY DON’T WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE SUBSTANCE OF PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS TALKING ABOUT FROM THE
ECONOMY TO NATIONAL SECURITY.
AN SUBSTANTIVELY, THERE WERE A
LOT OF FANTASTIC POINTS REALLY
HIGHLIGHT WHY PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
GOING TO END UP GETTING
REELECTED.
I WILL TELL, IF YOU’RE OUT THERE
SUPPORTER OF PRESIDENT TRUMP,
CAMPAIGN LIKE YOU’RE BEHIND
REGARDLESS OF WHAT ANY POLL EVER
SHOWS.
GOOD, BAD, OR INDIFFERENT.
YOU GOT TO FIGHT FOR IT.
YOU CAN’T TAKE ANYTHING FOR
GRANTED.
LOSING ISN’T AN OPTION.
EVERYTHING IS AT STAKE.
GET OUT AFTER IT.
FORGET ABOUT THE POLLS.
YOU HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO IS
GETTING GOOD THINGS DONE.
HE WANTS TO GET MORE DONE FOR
THE COUNTRY.
PETE: CONGRESSMAN TO YOUR POINT,
EFFECTIVE CAMPAIGNING CONTRAST
SPEECH WHAT THE WORLD WILL LOOK
LIKE BETWEEN THE TWO.
THERE IS VIDEO MSNBC, 4:03 P.M.,
CENTRAL TIME, TULSA TIME,
LITERALLY AN ENTRANCE FOR TRUMP
SUPPORTERS BLOCKED BY BLACK
LIVES MATTERS PROTESTERS.
THEY REPORTED ON THE DEMOCRATS
FAVORITE CHANNEL, MSNBC.
THE PRESIDENT TALKED ABOUT THE
LEFT AND THEIR ATTEMPTS TO ERASE
HISTORY.
>> THE BEYOND HINGED LEFT-WING
MOB IS TRYING TO VANDALIZE OUR
HISTORY, TEAR DOWN OUR STATUES
AND PUNISH, CANCEL AND PERSECUTE
ANYONE WHO DOES NOT CONFIRM TO
THEIR DEMANDS FOR ABSOLUTE AND
TOTAL CONTROL.
WE’RE NOT CONFORMING.
THAT IS WHY WE’RE HERE ACTUALLY.
[APPLAUSE]
THIS CRUEL CAMPAIGN OF
CENSORSHIP AROUND EXCLUSION
VIOLATES EVERYTHING WE HOLD DEAR
AS AMERICANS.
PETE: WHY DOES THIS RESONATE
WITH PEOPLE SO MUCH?
>> BECAUSE THIS IS A CROWD THAT
DOESN’T WANT TO SEE OUR COUNTRY
TORN DOWN.
THEY DON’T WANT TO SEE OUR
COUNTRY BURNT DOWN.
THEY’RE TIRED OF WATCHING ALL
THE LOOTING THAT HAS BEEN GOING
ON.
THEY WANT TO SEE OUR COUNTRY
LIFTED UP.
THEY WANT TO UNITE WITH FELLOW
AMERICANS.
THE TOLERANCE WAS INSIDE OF THAT
ROOM.
YOU SAW A LOT OF PEOPLE
HOLDING -- SITTING NEXT TO A
SECTION OF BLACKS FOR TRUMP.
YOU SAW VETERANS IN THE CROWD
AND ALL SORTS OF MINORITYS AND
DIFFERENT VIEWPOINTS.
YOU HAD AN INCLUSIVE ARENA
FILLED WITH PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
UNITE FOR A BETTER COUNTRY AND
YOU PUT ON THE TV AND YOU’RE
WATCHING INDIVIDUALS TRYING TO
TEAR DOWN OUR COUNTRY IN SO MANY
DIFFERENT WAYS.
SO THAT CONTRAST IS CRYSTAL
CLEAR.
THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT TO
HIGHLIGHT IT.
WE WOULD LIKE TO PUT UP, YOU
KNOW, MORE REFLECTIONS ON,
WHETHER IT IS A FOUNDING FATHER
OF OUR COUNTRY, YOU KNOW, OR
OTHERS WHO SERVED IN THE
MILITARY.
WE WANT TO CELEBRATE AMERICA.
WE WANT TO CELEBRATE OUR
CONSTITUTION.
OUR FREEDOMS, OUR LIBERTIES.
WE WANT TO DEFEND THEM AN
PROTECT THEM.
MEANWHILE WE’RE WATCHING PEOPLE
LOOKING TO TEAR IT ALL DOWN.
IT’S A SAD CONTRAST BUT
EFFECTIVE ONE TOO TO POINT OUT.
JEDEDIAH: CONGRESSMAN, I WANT TO
ASK YOU QUICKLY ABOUT NEW YORK
BECAUSE IT IS A BIG DAY FOR
NEW YORK CITY TOMORROW.
THEY WILL ENTER PHASE TWO,
ALLOWING SHOPPING, OUTDOOR
DINING WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT?
YOUR DISTRICT ON LONG ISLAND IS
MOVING TOWARDS PHASE THREE.
HOW DO YOU THINK THIS WILL TO?
HOW DO YOU ANTICIPATE THIS WILL
WORK OUT.
>> LONG ISLAND TO MOVING TO
PHASE THREE THIS UPCOMING
WEDNESDAY, EXPECTED TO.
NEW YORK CITY MOVING INTO PHASE
TWO.
THE ECONOMY NEEDS TO GET
REOPENED.
THE NUMBERS HAVE BEEN VERY LOW
OVER THE COURSE OF THE LAST FEW
WEEKS.
ON SOME DIFFERENT LEVELS WHAT
WAS BEING FOLLOWED.
AND WHAT WAS CRAZY IS WHAT, IS
BEFORE YOU SAW NEW YORK CITY
MOVING INTO PHASE ONE OF THE
ECONOMY REOPENING YOU HAD TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE MOVING
INTO PHASE 11 OF RIOTING AND
LOOTING, NOT JUST PROTESTING BUT
WHAT THEY TOOK, THEY TOOK THEIR
ACTIVITIES TO THE NEXT LEVEL
THAT GOT A WHOLE LOT OF PEOPLE
HURT.
I WOULD POINT OUT, WHILE YOU’RE
WATCHING MAYBE 25,000 PEOPLE WHO
WILL GATHER TOGETHER FOR A
PROTEST SAY IN BROOKLYN, YOU’RE
CAPPING HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATIONS
AT 150.
THAT DOESN’T MAKE SENSE.
YOU’RE CAPPING HOUSES OF WORSHIP
AT 25%.
THAT DOESN’T MAKE SENSE.
YOU’RE NOT ALLOWING KIDS TO PLAY
AROUND IN THE LOCAL PARK WHERE
JEWISH KIDS LIKE TO GO PLAY,
MAYBE JUST A FEW BLOCKS FROM
WHERE THE PROTEST WAS GOING ON,
SO I WOULD ACTUALLY ENCOURAGE
THE GOVERNOR TO LOOK WHERE THE
INCONSISTENCY IS ACROSS THE
BOARD AND THAT WILL LEAD TO
RESENTMENTS, PEOPLE ARE TIRED OF
BEING COUPED UP.
THEY WANT TO GET OUT THERE TO
ENJOY THEIR LIVES.
IT IS TIME TO REOPEN.
WE CAN BE REOPENING FASTER AND
DO IT SAFELY.
PETE: PHASE 11, DIDN’T KNOW WAS